all right there's a new report that the
Trump White House has been hiding not
only the transcript with the Ukrainian
president's phone call with Donald Trump
but also transcripts with Vladimir Putin
as well as Saudi royals including the
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman and of
course anyone surprised why wouldn't
they who would believe that the White
House has this entire other computer
system for hiding things and the only
thing they hid was the transcript with
the Ukrainian president of course
they're using it for other things and
there are new reports which say that the
transcripts from calls with the Russian
President Vladimir Putin and a number of
members of the Saudi royal family again
including Mohammed bin Salman are hidden
on a separate server where does that
ring a bell
wasn't it Hillary who had problems with
private servers and improperly handling
information another instance of
projection from Donald Trump and of
course we already have the whistleblower
complaining alleging that this was done
with Donald Trump's Ukraine phone call
and now the New York Times and CNN have
been told by other sources that actually
this is being done with all sorts of
communications so this is number one
much worse than just one phone call and
then number two it's also much worse
than just Trump because we are now
getting more and more names of people
that are being pulled into the circle of
knowledge of who was aware that this was
going on there are allegations that
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and then
national security adviser John Bolton
were the only people in the room for
some of these calls which were then
buried there are now committees that
want to question Mike Pompeo and John
Bolton Trump said he would have the most
transparent administration in history
the opposite is true going to new
lengths Nixonian lengths even more than
nick Sounion lengths to hide transcripts
the Trump administration has ignored
subpoenas of all sorts of documents
meant to increase transparency they were
asked for lease agreements from Trump
properties they were asked for documents
about the transfer of nuclear technology
to Saudi Arabia they just ignore all of
those requests when a whistleblower
forward to try to expose some of this
stuff trump is caught on a recording
which I played for you last week hinting
that either the whistleblower or the
people or person who informed the
whistleblower should be killed like we
used to do to people who committed
treason this is not transparent this is
transparently corrupt better said and
they just don't care and if you've been
following the administration you're not
surprised at the minutiae of it but what
you really have to understand you know
we're we're starting to think
increasingly in post Trump terms because
either in a year-and-a-half or in five
and a half years scary to think about
Trump's going to go and the long lasting
impact will be not only all of those
judges that he will have appointed by
the time he's done who will control the
judiciary for a very very long time not
only the alliances with other countries
are historic Democratic allies that
Donald Trump has ruined relationships
with that will be one of the legacies
but what Donald Trump has done is so
fundamentally at odds with democracy and
what you have to understand is that
there is actually in most democracies
even you know liberal democracies there
is a portion of the population that
wants tyranny or at least they're open
to tyranny rather than democracy as long
as they are the ones who get to enforce
it and that is maybe the most accurate
way to describe what we have in the
Trump administration we can point out
the individual authoritarian tendencies
we can point out Trump being just so
smitten with Duterte and Putin and Kim
jong-un and you know the whole list of
also Naro whoever you want to include
and being increasingly distant and at
odds with just Liberal Democratic
leaders Germany the UK well not the UK
anymore now that it's Trump - Boris
Johnson but you get the idea we can
point that out but what underlies this
is that we really have a segment of
these right-wing authoritarians that are
about tyranny as long as it's a tyranny
they get to enforce and that is extreme
extremely scary and allegedly and we'll
talk about this next there are some
Republicans who if they voted on
impeachment on a secret ballot would be
willing to remove Donald Trump and
that's what I want to talk about next